-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy, Grammy and award --
Academy Award, excuse me,
winning rapper and actor.
He makes his Broadway debut in
"Between Riverside and Crazy,"
which is playing
at the Hayes Theater.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Common, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Hey, what's going on, Seth?
-I'm so happy to have you.
Thank you for being here
on a show day.
I know you've got to go and be
on the Broadway stage tonight.
-Yes, it's amazing,
I'm thinking like, wow, I've got
a show tonight.
It's amazing thing to happen,
and I'm here with you.
-Because this is your --
this your Broadway debut.
-Yes.
-The last time you were in
a play was a school play,
is that accurate?
-Very true, very true.
-Wow.
-"Christmas Carol" when I was
like in second grade.
-Who were you
in "Christmas Carol?"
-I was Tiny Tim.
-Oh, well, look at that.
You've outgrown the role.
-Yes, yes.
-It happens to all our best
Tiny Tims.
-Yeah, and I didn't get a lot
of love for my role in that,
so that didn't help my -- that
didn't help my acting career.
-At second grade, you said I'm
going to take a break,
I'm gonna establish myself
in a lot of other mediums...
-Yes, that's it.
-...and then I will
return to the stage.
-Yeah.
My mother kind of orchestrated
that break because
she was like -- she kept talking
about how great
my friend did in the play.
[ Laughter ]
And really didn't mention much
about my work,
so I was like, okay, I get it.
-She was like, you know,
Common, Tiny Tim
is supposed to be
a sympathetic character.
-Yeah, exactly, exactly.
I was playing him too cool.
-Yeah, way too cool.
Your Tiny Tim was way too cool.
Everybody's like he gonna get
knocked down a peg.
So you -- this is a play,
wonderful family drama.
It's about a widowed ex-cop.
You play his previously
incarcerated son.
-Yes.
-Gorgeous play.
This is a play that had
been off Broadway.
Most of the cast is back.
You're the new kid on the block.
Even with all your success, does
it feel -- do you feel
like the rookie with this
group of incredible actors?
-Oh, I feel so much
like the rookie,
like a freshman in high school,
right?
Because it's like they have been
together for so long,
and they just know the ropes
of theater, like,
and it's just
an incredible cast.
They really like superheroes.
Really, they just -- you know,
everybody might not know
each actor's name all the time,
but these actors are just --
this cast is phenomenal.
So I felt like I was joining
a cast of superheroes,
and I was like, hey,
I got something, too.
But they gave me a little love.
They gave me love
from the beginning,
and then once they saw
how, like, passionate I was,
and I was coming in
understanding
I had a lot to learn.
And no matter what I did before,
they knew more than me
and they're more
experienced than me.
So I took it from that
perspective, and also just in
gratitude of being able to be
doing a play, man,
doing theater, doing Broadway.
Like, I didn't dream of that
when I was on the south side
of Chicago
thinking I would be --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You obviously -- you're no
stranger to live performance,
you're no stranger to being on a
stage in front of an audience.
Are there technical
aspects of this
that have shocked you
or surprised you?
-Yeah, I'm almost embarrassed
to say, but the truth is,
thank God I have, like,
friends who are into theater,
because a director
friend of mine,
Owarya, who I work with often,
she said, okay,
a couple of things.
This is before my
first rehearsal.
She said you be on time,
on time, early is on time.
So I was early every day,
but she also said,
do you know where stage --
what downstage and upstage is
and stage left
and stage right.
And I really didn't know.
[ Laughter ]
So I was grateful she sent me
a diagram with that.
And it's all type of rules,
like signing in.
You sign in when you come into
the theater,
like signing in for work,
like you punching in for work.
And if you don't like --
if I don't leave the building,
I still have to sign in,
meaning we have two
shows in a day.
I sign in for the first show.
Even if I don't leave the
building, I still have
to sign in for the second show.
It's just theater rules
that I'm just like, wow, okay,
but I love the culture.
-There's no sign-in sheet
at rap concerts?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, I know we've got
a big rap concert.
You've got to sign in.
[ Laughter ]
--Boy, there would
be no concerts.
-What about -- You know,
obviously you're on stage,
and you know as a performer,
as a rapper,
you connect with the audience.
That's got to be a really
important thing.
In a show, you want to connect
with them as well,
but it must be a totally
different tool kit.
-Yeah, no, a live concert
is a whole different thing.
Because, you know, when I'm
performing at a live concert,
I'm like come on, say hoo,
yeah, let's rock it.
I'm directly to the crowd.
You know, in a play, it's --
you're playing this character,
and really you're interacting
and connection is with the other
actors on stage.
And the audience is a part
of the play, but you're not
directing your energy or
thoughts towards the audience.
It's towards the other actors.
And emotionally,
the places you have to go,
even though I play -- I play --
"Between Riverside and Crazy"
is really a lot of laughs,
but it also has a lot of emotion
to it and grit.
So to go to those emotional
places is much different
than rocking out on stage.
You know what I mean?
-Both cases, live performance,
things can go wrong.
Has anything gone wrong on stage
in the play yet?
-Well, I mean, for me, like,
it's a point in the play
where I'm using this -- where
I'm giving something away.
But I'm using a wheelchair.
And I got stuck in the
wheelchair really quick
for a minute and couldn't move.
But I don't know if everybody
noticed it, but I did.
I kind of laughed to myself.
And sometimes, you know,
in the play I'm making
a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich in one of the scenes,
and that doesn't
always go right.
[ Laughter ]
But overall it's just like --
I've been in concerts
where the sound has went out
and you just have to
rap out loud to people.
So nothing makes me too scared,
too nervous,
but I must say, we have had a
couple of little trip ups.
-You've never had to take out
your map of where stage left
and stage right is?
-Not in a rap --
not in a rap show.
-I got a lot more
questions for you.
We'll be right back with more
from Common, everybody.